you do
so like if you're a hardware if you work
hard every day that you're a
hard-working person if you're nice every
day then you're a nice person
I can work hard every day you know and
be lazy I'm saying you don't have to be
lazy I don't
categorize things I don't like
yeah I'm a hard worker I work very very
hard but that doesn't make me who I am
okay it does what makes you who you are
I'm just me I'm like my father I am a
millionaire I'm not a millionaire yet no
no I'm not actually I said can I just
say it like and then
I don't have to have a million dollars
what is it called websites let's say I
am I'm like yeah I'm manifesting my
truth or manifesting my truth so I will
be a millionaire soon but I'm not right
now but I am a hard worker but that
doesn't that doesn't that is not just
Hawaiian I'm not just a hard worker I
didn't say just but okay so if you're a
hard worker how are you a hard worker
I'll just make sure it happen how
however I make things happen but I'm
saying like you have to work hard to be
a hard worker
yes but that doesn't make me who like
that doesn't like that doesn't that is
not just who I am not just okay I didn't
say that was the okay so just just go to
your point because I don't understand
what you're I I think you do understand
I think I'm just trying to not but
that's okay
but but okay your habits are who you are
so if I if I drink every day I'm an
alcoholic
I could be a nice addict I could have
more than one quality and it's the same
thing like if you sleep with a bunch of
men for 10 years how does he know that
you're gonna stop when he marries you
like you are who your habits and the one
thing that men value is loyalty like
they want a girl that's down for them no
matter what like through the ups and the
Downs especially now because if they get
married to you like they're in a
contract that you are paid to leave so
it's it's we have less incentive for men
to get married they might be paid to
leave no not really yeah very rare rare
it's only men only win 13 of alimony
cases it doesn't matter but if you marry
me you might be paid to leave
well it's only 13
. and and child support is very little
too I think it's under 90.
so so I mean you could talk about the
exception but we're talking about the
rules so if you're a hoe for 10 years
how does he know you're going to be
loyal it's just like the same thing like
if if if he cheated in every single
relationship he'd ever been in I would
think Hmm he's going to cheat
he's probably gonna cheat so if she's
been a hoe for 10 years how does he know
you won't get bored and go back to the
streets
she's in the streets it's a difference
because if I'm a prostitute and I'm
having sex with people and I'm hoeing
because that's a thing right that's
different but if I'm just if I want to
have sex with different men
it's it's my choice some women don't
even know that they're a prostitute do
you understand that some women don't
know and don't believe that they're a
prostitute they're getting paid with
experience instead of actual physical
cash to realistically be lured in and
have sex oh my gosh you know what I
asked guys on the street I said would
you rather have like you got two girls
one has fifty thousand dollars in credit
card debt that you have to pay off and
one has 50 bodies who you picking
that sounds like each body is worth at
least a thousand dollars I try to up it
I try to up it I'm like I wonder how
high it'll go until they I think 100 I
swear to God what number would you
switch it so it's a hundred thousand
dollars you have to pay off for 50 Baht
like what number do you switch it well
honestly I it don't really matter listen
I didn't like especially like if if you
went to college
if you went to college and you don't do
that career was like let's say that's
what a hundred two hundred thousand
dollars on average yeah for you to do a
different job up no she broke she's
never paying at all you have to pay off
all of it what I'm saying is I'm still
all that money
whether or not I graduate I still owe
that money so I'm going at least
at least a quarter million at least a
quarter million if I could give the
government 250
000 for a degree that I don't use
I'll I'll go with a quarter million to
debt for a girl with less than 50 bodies
but that's about 50 bodies you know how
hard it was for me to get 50 bodies me
me me
so like if you have 50 bodies I'm like
yo you're bugging absolutely not and
that [ __ ] don't even look the same
there's no way after 50 bodies your [ __ ]
look the same you know what I'm talking
about
you know what I'm talking about she must
not be taking care of it no matter what
you take care of you got 50 bodies 20 of
them was raw because the nine times out
of ten if you're already exposing
yourself like that you're not even
really caring about customs
well and it's like 50 bodies like men
don't want to deal with our trauma
so like even Andrew even Andrew Tate
talks about he doesn't really like women
under the age of 25 and people were so
offended by them
I get it because look I I mean I'm I'm
almost 26 and so it's like it's like
every relationship we go through we have
trauma that comes with it like by the
time you're 25 you've probably had your
heart broken and who has to deal with
that your husband and it's like
because we're women we don't shut up
let's just be real you're not gonna tell
them anything like what are you gonna
like just and like and then if you don't
tell them anything that's not really
good either because men don't like a
girl that's not vulnerable like being
part of part of being feminine is being
open and vulnerable I'm not feminine
that's why yeah I mean probably not and
I don't listen I
I agree with you bro like what's it like
personal homie like apple today me and
bro are gonna be on the call like
they say I need a therapist I think I
just need you
like because I know I'm not bugging I
just need somebody to understand what
I'm trying to say and that's why women
don't want to have certain conversations
with people
talking about oh if you do this you're a
[ __ ] if you do this you're a hoe If you
do this you're a hoe so it's like when
are we ever going to be able to be
vulnerable and talk about what we want
it like if I want to be able to speak
why is that a mistake you don't know you
don't know everyone's right if I said to
you I don't know everyone's life but
like that's like me complaining right
that's like me complaining like yo I got
felonies I'm not a criminal my body
count is has not affected anyone else
okay you might think my puppy looks
differently it feels differently
I don't know because I could tell you I
have three kids and my place is tight
okay and you know the women that have
one you don't have there are women that
had one okay and are out here and only
have one husband Nations
because what I'm trying to say is that
some women need to understand as serious
as you take that it's as serious as we
take your body count
so it's not about what you did and who
you affected realistically you affected
yourself because you yourself and I
believe when you have a lot of men who
are inside of you you change you you
carry baggage you might carry
self-resentment you might carry identity
issues these are things that usually
lead you to a path of having so much sex
you might have been in a position where
you were financially struggling and you
used your body to gain yourself out of
that struggle right there's a bunch of
different reasons but but what I'm
saying is at the end of the day is it's
not fair for people in general to ask
people to forgive them for their past
but they're not willing to forgive
others for them everyone has a choice
just like you have the choice to not
want a woman with a certain body count
you know what I'm saying that is your
choice but that is because most men's
choices you already limited yourself let
me tell you something most men are
living with a woman that's body count is
not what they think it is okay number
one and guess what they have taken them
it's not necessarily the point maybe
they didn't ask maybe they didn't ask so
it's I'm just saying everyone is
entitled to their choice okay
um so then if Everyone's entitled to
your choice like why do you keep arguing
with them
I'm not we're trying to I'm giving my
point yeah okay everyone sometimes if
he's nobody he keeps saying like this is
our choice and then you keep saying well
it shouldn't be your choice I don't know
no he didn't say he this is the first
time number one he said it's most men's
choices and I said Everyone's entitled
to their choice but but the thing is
that you don't have to come here and say
oh you've been a [ __ ] why not
it was your choice to be a [ __ ] it's my
choice to not want us you don't get to
categorize me or anyone and I'm not
saying this is my personal experience
but I'm just saying you don't categorize
women don't want consequences and this
is the thing like we're so used to being
bailed out of poor decisions like
because women are built out of
everything literally like if you if you
wanna if you want to get pregnant if you
get pregnant by the wrong and then
actually I'll start first if you if you
sleep around what do you have birth
control if you if you sleep around and
you get pregnant anyways you have an
abortion if you sleep around and you and
you get pregnant by the right guy you
know you can put them on child support
if you if you sleep around and get
pregnant you can trap him and you know
get married take half also you know and
women are just so used to being bailed
out of every decision that like that we
can't handle the truth and like that's
the consequence you sleep around your
slide like that is what it is yeah as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
or thanks below every donation helps and
it helps make what we do possible